cinéma avec un événement comme à chaque
fois que sort un film du maître de
l'animation japonais miyazaki considéré
comme un dieu vivant dans son pays
le château ambulant et sa dernière
création si vous avez aimé le voyage de
chihiro vous adorerez son nouveau film
parce qu'elle deschamps eric de lannion
le château ambulant un drôle de château
fait de bric et de broc mais capable de
parcourir la terre entière
un drôle de château habité par un enfant
une vieille femme est un magicien
retirer loin du monde
voilà la nouvelle création d'un grand
poète de l'animation hayao miyazaki une
création peuplée d'humains mais aussi
d'esprit car comme les actifs derrière
la réalité se cache tout un monde
féerique auquel seuls les âmes d'enfants
dans accès on dit souvent quand on est
vieux on ne s'étonne plus de rien pour
moi ce n'est pas vrai j'ai 63 ans et
tous m'étonne je continue de trouver le
monde étrange et complexe son crâne en
20 ans mia qui est devenu l'empereur de
l'animation japonaise ces films ont
engrangé des dizaines de millions
d'entrées dans le monde
ses oeuvres on est ici dans les studios
ghibli à tokyo tandis que les visiteurs
affluent dans ce musée gigantesque
véritable équivalent de disneyland mais
où l'on baigne dans les créations
étranges ou poétique du maître entre
léonard de vinci et jules verne
si j'avais vécu à une époque où il n'y
avait pas de dessin animé j'aurais été
artisan j'aurais fabriquer des choses
hayao miazaki avec quatre ans aux
moments d'hiroshima
dans ses dessins animés il n'a jamais
cessé de fustiger la galerie de défendre
la nature tel un sage engager la société
de consommation est inclus
si l'homme continue de se couper de ses
racines il court à la catastrophe
et on ne pourra pas comme dans son film
décidé de changer le monde
en tournant simplement la poignée de la
porte magique nous n'en avons qu'un nous
dit miyazaki et il faut le préserver